[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition du 7 8 journal de tv 60,18 le
tour de l'actualité locale et régionale
tout de suite les titres de ce mardi à
26 février
le texte doit être voté d'ici la fin de
l'année le règlement local de la
publicité intercommunale se dessine à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la semaine
dernière les élus en ont adopté les
principales orientations une grande
enquête publique sera lancée
prochainement
ils sont à l'origine du grand débat
national les gilets jaunes ont tenu
leurs propres réunions à elancourt plus
de 450 personnes réunies au palais des
sports autour de certaines figures de
mouvement à une première dans les
yvelines reportage enfin utiliser
l'expérience des sportifs de haut niveau
pour améliorer ses performances
professionnelles objectif d'une
conférence organisée au vélodrome
nationale à montigny le bretonneux la
soirée a permis de mettre en évidence
les liens entre le monde du sport et de
l'entreprise
plusieurs centaines de mètres cubes de
pétrole déversés dans des champs des
affluents également de la môle de
retoucher conséquences de la rupture du
pipeline à d'ile-de-france de total qui
relie à la raffinerie du havre à celle
de grandpuits en seine-et-marne une
fuite d'hydrocarbures constaté hier au
niveau de la commune de tout y est les
opérations de dépollution se poursuivent
le 'pipeline' a été arrêté un périmètre
de sécurité établi des barrages
flottants et des camions de pompage sont
à l'oeuvre
total indique que l'écoulement
d'hydrocarbures a été stoppée le groupe
s'engage à prendre à sa charge
l'ensemble des frais de remise en état
des terres agricoles est également les
conséquences sur les récoltes
l'île de france qui vit depuis quelques
jours un épisode de pollution le pic
devrait être atteint dans la journée de
demain la préfecture de police a donc
décidé de la mise en place de la
circulation à différencier pour la
journée de demain mercredi à l'intérieur
d'un périmètre délimité par à la 86 les
véhicules dotés d'une vignette critères
de 0 à 3 pourront au boulet est d'après
l'agent saada tu as plus de trois cent
soixante douze mille voitures du
département seront concernés demain par
à l'interdiction de circulation
saint-quentin-en-yvelines travaille en
ce moment sur son url pays le règlement
local de la publicité intercommunale il
a pour objectif notamment d'améliorer le
cadre de vie des habitants de
l'agglomération
le conseil communautaire vient
d'approuver les six orientations de ce
rlp y le texte sera voté avant la fin de
l'année les images de nicolas landry 495
le nombre de publicités recensés sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est pour mieux les encadrer qui est
elle à bord et ce rlp y règlement local
de publicité intercommunale les élus du
conseil communautaire en ont validé les
principales orientations une phase
supplémentaires après la concertation
publique et les discussions au sein des
12 conseils municipaux des communes de
l'agglomération
le règlement local de publicité en plus
touche au cadre de vie touche aussi à
notre quotidien
et puis également à l'activité
économique et donc faut qu'on arrive à
trouver un texte qui fasse consensus qui
soit équilibrée pas d'excès de tous les
côtés et que jose d'équilibré qui fasse
qu'on puisse maintenir notre objectif de
lutter contre la pollution visuelle et
lumineuse mais aussi de respecter le
cadre légal
on est d'accord tout en préservant le
dynamisme économique de notre territoire
au total six orientations définies pour
ce règlement de la publicité parmi les
principales interdire les publicités
murales scellés au sol ou sur bâche dans
les zones d'habitat les autorisés dans
les zones commerciales et d'activités
réduire le nombre de panneaux et en
limiter leur format enfin l extinction d
affichage lumineux notamment les
publicités numériques entre 22 heures et
6 heures du matin 67 élus ont voté pour
cette délibération deux se sont abstenus
à coignières on craint notamment la
multiplication des publicités le long de
la nationale 10 on nous propose est
effectivement rl pays qui était en
principe je dirais restrictif qui devait
réduire en partie la publicité mais au
paradoxe à coignières le rl pays
finalement va accroître la publicité
dans nos zones d'activités
donc il ya là effectivement un problème
de son côté le collectif résistance à
l'agression publicitaire dénoncent un
projet peu protecteur le rl pays doit
être arrêtée définitivement avant l'été
une grande enquête publique sera ensuite
lancée avant un vote du règlement
d'ici la fin de l'année des gilet jaune
à elancourt une réunion était organisée
au palais des sports avec des figures de
ce mouvement qui a engendré le grand
débat national près de 450 personnes ont
participé à ce rendez-vous le reportage
de michael et demi d'euros
des gilets jaunes dans les gradins du
palais des sports des longs cours une
rencontre débat entre citoyens était
organisée ce vendredi 22 février par des
figures du mouvement
une première dans les yvelines mais le
concept n'est pas inédit en france ont
fait en moyenne des salles de 1000
personnes et on prépare des salles
encore plus grande pour juste faire voir
que on existe on n'est pas des foule
haineuse ya pas de casseurs dans les
salles donc on fait des débats on va
faire des vagues genre on pose des
questions on va répondre aux questions
et les gens vont être un peu plus au
courant de ce qu'on peut demander ce
qu'on peut réclamer pour un peu plus de
justice sociale et fiscale dans la salle
plus de 450 curieux et militants venus
principalement des yvelines et des
départements limitrophes avaient fait le
déplacement des gens en échange entre
citoyens on y retrouve tous bords
politiques
donc on est dans le concret pour moi des
dents concret voilà je pense qu'on va
ressortir plus intelligents qu'on était
entré je pense en plus informés en tout
cas après qu'est-ce qu'elle sera le la
pacte sur le reste de la population
c'est à nous de porter la bonne parole
après à nous deux
d'essayer de convaincre les gens s'ils
ne sont pas déjà convaincu au total et
gilet jaune et leurs représentants ont
pu débattre pendant plus de trois heures
ce soir là un concept qui pourrait se
développer selon les organisateurs ça
permet d'échanger dans un autre cadre
ce qu on échange beaucoup au coeur des
manifestations et c'est pas un contexte
idéal pour discuter avec les autres il
est jeune donc pourquoi pas avoir ce
type de format là je trouve que c'est
une bonne évolution de la mobilisation
les organisateurs n'excluent pas de
revenir dans les prochains mois dans les
yvelines pour toucher encore plus de
citoyens pages économiques dirigeante
est un champion le thème d'une
conférence qui était proposé au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines objectifs
durant la soirée mettre en avant les
similitudes entre le monde du sport et
celui de l'entreprise retour avec
aurélie rose et nicolas landry découvrir
les outils utilisés par les sportifs de
haut niveau pour améliorer ses
performances professionnelles c'était le
but de cette conférence imaginé par le
centre des jeunes dirigeants
d'entreprise dans les yvelines
une association qui regroupe une
trentaine d'adhérents fringer relance un
champion parce qu'il doit se préparer
beaucoup ça s'improvise pas business et
donc l'idée c'est effectivement de fer
parallèle entre le sport et le dirigeant
pour travailler sur tout ce qui est
préparation pour être au top le jour j
atteindre un objectif aller plus loin ou
encore savoir rebondir des valeurs
communes au monde de l'entreprise et au
monde sportif
le rôle du coach s'est toujours gardé
les yeux fixés pour moi sur l'objectif
ensuite c'est ensemble avec l'équipe
qu'on définit une action qu'on peut
dérouler pour y arriver on parle souvent
du bien-être en entreprise
la question c'est comment optimiser ses
compétences personnelles pour pouvoir
rester à son meilleur niveau
développer son potentiel et faire les
choses avec le moins de fatigue possible
à la fois mentale et physique
parmi les intervenants le septuple
champion du monde de vélo sur piste
pour françois pervis le monde de
l'entreprise a beaucoup à apprendre du
monde du sport de haut niveau qu'il faut
savoir se poser les bonnes questions il
faut savoir optimiser
les forces les forces en présences
savoir aussi bien s'entourer pour pour
créer une équipe autour de soi et et
pour pouvoir soit faire les chiffres une
entreprise et moi à gagner gagner me
médaille d'or qu après les jeux
olympiques à tokyo en 2020 le cycliste a
déjà préparé sa reconversion avec la
création d'une société
preuve que le monde du sport et le monde
de l'entreprise sont deux chemins
parallèles qui peuvent bel et bien se
rejoindre et on parle uniquement de
sport cette fois ci avec ce match inédit
à plaisir le rugby club de la ville
accueillait une équipe écossaise le
week-end dernier une rencontre dans le
cadre du tournoi des six nations les
images d'aurélie ronze la voix de
michael et demi d'euros des entraîneurs
en kilt c'était l'image insolite de ce
samedi 23 février au stade robert barran
de plaisir le club écossais de nine 10
go est venu affronter sur le terrain une
équipe composée de joueurs locaux dans
le cadre d'un partenariat créé en
parallèle du tournoi des six nations
sur le terrain les français l'emportent
38 à 24
on a beau faire la fête la veille sur le
terrain il ya pu y a plus d'amitié
pendant deux fois quarante minutes
donc bon match c'était un match très dur
aujourd'hui il beaucoup d'essais pour
les deux équipes très agréable très dur
beaucoup de joueurs ont été en
difficulté aujourd'hui mais nous allons
passer un bon moment après le match ce
rendez vous était également l'occasion
pour les français de comparer leur jeu à
celui des écossais je dirais engagé et
mobile c'est des joueurs en à ses
mobiles
assez léger qui se déplace beaucoup donc
voilà c'est pas c'est pas comme le jeu
français où on a plus plus l'habitude
d'avoir d'avoir des gros de fixer là
c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus rapide
ça joue sajou énormément ce partenariat
organisé pour la première fois plaisir a
convaincu les dirigeants du club c'est
bien parce que ça je pense qu'on peut
développer des échanges ne serait ce
qu'avec aller une fois tous les deux ans
donc ce qui se passe avec leur entente
là
on peut même prévoir d'y aller avec des
jeunes minimes des cadets une bonne
expérience pour rencontrer d'autres
cultures
après avoir déjeuné ensemble les joueurs
sont ensuite allés voir le match du
quinze de france face aux quinze du
chardon un stade de france et là aussi
les français l'ont emporté en ces
vacances d'hiver on a bien de la chance
très ensoleillée le programme des
activités est fourni sur le territoire
notamment au musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines et visite guidée de
l'exposition soyons sports le mercredi
27 février et samedi 9 mars vous pourrez
y construire votre parfait kit du
supporter et jouer aux petits urbanistes
ou encore aux paysagistes de défi lancé
ce jeudi réalisé en équipe une maquette
de votre propre ville nouvelle vendredi
autres maquettes à imaginer celles d'un
parc idéal des initiations aussi à l'art
contemporain avec sculptures dans la
ville ce samedi 2 mars pour la deuxième
semaine des vacances mercredi 6 mars une
découverte d'un patrimoine du territoire
la commanderie à elancourt visite puis
atelier de reproduction de la façade du
17 mars vous casserez et les idées
reçues sur le béton le matériau le plus
utilisé au monde visite jus pédagogique
fabrication d'un échantillon et pour
terminer ses congés le 8 mars un jeu de
l'oie géant pour découvrir les espaces
verts de la ville toutes ces animations
sont au tarif de 3 et 4 euros et sur
réservation
et puis à voisins le bretonneux le
centre alfred de vigny propose également
et se mobilisent pendant ses congés de
nombreuses activités qui ont débuté
samedi dernier avec une après midi jeux
de société une quarantaine de jeux
vintage ou plus récent était proposée
aux jeunes et adultes présents les
propos sont recueillis par aurélie rose
bonbon s'est rendu compte qu'à chaque
début de vacances il y avait un petit
public intéressé pour venir jouer le
samedi en famille autour de jeux
classiques et puis un petit peu nouveau
on a un partenariat avec asmodée qui
nous a fait des tons de jeu de nouveaux
d'anciens des classiques et c'est assez
sympathique de voir les parents venir
jouer ensemble ou même des ados venir
tout seul jouer à des jeux de société
cette semaine d'autres animations stages
robotique dessin ou encore spectacle
le programme complet bien sûr à
retrouver sur le site du centre alfred
de vigny je vous rappelle cette
information avant de vous laisser la
mise en place demain mercredi de la
circulation différencier en
ile-de-france à l'intérieur d'un
périmètre délimité par la 86e les
véhicules dotés d'une vignette critères
de 0 à 3 pourront rouler une mesure bien
sûr mise en place en ile de france qui
vit depuis quelques jours un épisode de
pollution
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal ce soir
sur tv 78 également l'émission 7,8
culture avec au programme expo
après-midi 100% japon et le festival
jazz à toute heure c'est à retrouver à
tout à l'heure sur cette chaîne voit la
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]